at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by athletic greens every year of course
people look for new ways to become
healthier to take their fitness and so
on to the next level for me step number
one is having some form of nutritional
insurance that's how I would look at it
and the nutritional insurance needs to
make sure all of my basic needs are met
all the boxes checked regardless of
travel schedule missed meals and so on
there going to be times in the new year
when your diet and exercise will get
interrupted life will interrupt it and
during those times you want a safety net
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
and my answer is inevitably athletic
greens it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Parrish show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens com forward slash Tim that is a
great deal on one of my favourite
products and it covers my basis each day
it is part of my routine and it leaves
me with less to worry about if for
instance I have to skip a meal or just
can't get a high quality meal so check
it out
go to athletic greens comm forward slash
Tim and learn all about it
this episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter you may have heard them
everywhere they're growing like crazy
they're an innovative platform for doing
several things but especially improving
the hiring process making it slick and
elegant and easy one of the hardest
parts of running any business growing
any business is finding and hiring the
right team I've seen this firsthand in
close to a hundred startups now god I'm
getting old from all over the world at
different stages of growth and nothing
can quite drain your resources and cost
you time and money like making mistakes
in hiring Zipp recruiter developed their
own system and their own platform for
helping you to solve two of the biggest
problems and bottlenecks for employers
posting jobs easily and then making it
even easier to find the best candidates
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
does in effect the opposite of what
you'd expect so they do not depend on
candidates finding you their technology
finds the right candidate for you and in
fact more than 80% of the jobs posted on
zip recruiter return a qualified
candidate based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours
so no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of that simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
unzip recruiters dashboard and as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show thanks
for that zip recruiter wants to allow
you to start posting jobs and trying
their services for free so if you're
thinking of hiring somebody you need to
find an executive assistant you need to
find a developer whatever it might be
try it out
just visit zip recruiter com forward
slash Tim and you can experience just
how zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all different sizes to
find the most qualified job candidates
again that's zip recruiter com a forward
slash Tim check it out give it a spin
well hello ladies and gentlemen Taha Aki
my silver Thor was a math Gong chief at
high or if you prefer Cantonese gung hay
fat choy I think that mangled that
because my Cantonese is crutch but Happy
New Year everybody
to all of my first time and long-term
listeners thank you for joining me once
again for another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show normally it is my job to
deconstruct a world-class performer over
two to three hours of interview and to
tease out the habits routines tactics
and so on that they apply in their lives
that you can borrow and apply in your
own it could range from favorite books
to nighttime rituals to the first 60
minutes of their day and so on in this
episode I'm going to take a slightly
different approach many of you have
asked over the last say six months
specifically after reading tools of
Titan's and try but mentors my last two
books how I process all the information
that I receive and that also came about
because I showed some people a
screenshot of the 392,000 unread email
that I have I've also been asked how I
make sense of the signal versus the
noise on social media and I suppose
delineate between the things that I
should try to absorb versus distractions
this episode will cover all those topics
and it will also answer a few questions
that have been asked many times that are
popular about building a world-class
Network and writing books specifically
answering the question should you write
a book or if you're doing it first
person should I write a book if you're
asking yourself that then I have some
thoughts because I am constantly asked
about book writing and publishing so I
hope that this episode this information
helps you to strengthen the signal to
discard some of the noise in the
upcoming year and that it makes every
piece of information that you receive
that you choose to process easier to
process so thanks for listening and
enjoy
social media let's talk about the
abusive spouse we all know that we'd go
back to cos they give us a flower and we
walk back under the internet and first
thing that happens is they throw a brick
out of a windows rewarding on the
sidewalk and catches us in the teeth
anyway a little dramatic maybe but
Internet's a rough place and social
media is certainly a full-contact sport
and I do have a few guidelines or
policies for myself that helped me to
maintain my sanity number one is that my
phone is on airplane mode I would say 80
plus percent of my day
this is particularly critical post
dinner all the way until I finish my
morning routine the next day so my phone
is almost never on our say off of
airplane mode when I'm in bed I don't
like the health implications
particularly and I don't want to go into
a reactive mode when I wake up I want to
have my meditation and/or exercise and
sitting down doing saying five-minute
Journal or determining my top one or two
priorities for the day while I have my
tea and then and only then once I have
calibrated my true north for the day and
my one or two must do two dues that make
everything else on the list easier or
irrelevant only then do I open the
window if I pull a proof car and let the
bullets start whizzing and that I'm only
referring to in the case of text
messages and potentially email I do not
have notifications on my phone for most
things but do not have email
notifications and did not have news
notifications that turned off all news
notifications I have no social media
notifications I want to be able to
select the exact times that I engage if
I engage on social media so a few
thoughts number one is that if you don't
want to amplify something or encourage
someone then star of a given say tweet
of oxygen so the first might default
action for negativity or attacks is
starve it of oxygen because I'll have
people deliberately attack me just to
provoke a response because it will get
them it will benefit them for me to
respond so I very very very rarely
respond to any type of tech on the
internet for many different reasons also
because it will then in almost a sunk
cost fallacy type of way engage me and
making me feel committed to engaging
right so if I send a retort and I think
it's addressed them or some in some way
defeated them and they respond I will
feel the inclination to respond yet
again and then you're just wrestling in
the mud with a pig makes you filthy
makes the pig happy so I opt out
whenever possible and I don't remember
exactly who this is attributed to but
the quote is the best revenge is living
well so that's that's how I feel it's
the best revenge is living well and the
best way to live well is to ignore
things and the even better way to live
well is to not see things so I never
look at for instance home screens on say
Twitter I will look at my at replies
because many of my readers and listeners
are very good at finding things I find
really really interesting and fast and
say hey Tam I thought you'd really enjoy
this study related to a BSA hey Tim you
shared this video about blabbity blah
and fybel at friday newsletter i thought
you'd love this video that very few
people have seen outside of poland
awesome fantastic that's the stuff I
want to see so Twitter is useful for
specifically looking at feedback via at
mentions but also connecting with
celebrities or well-known people I
should say who then can communicate with
you if they follow you or if you can
catalyze you can encourage them to
follow you in a bunch of indirect ways
like retweeting things they've done
favoriting things they've done following
them doing all three of those things at
the same time or in in rapid succession
then you can DM with them and neither of
you has to exchange personal information
that is how I've got probably 40 of the
people who are in some ways above my
weight class to be involved with tribe
mentors but the the different social
media networks also to me represent
different types of neighborhoods so
Twitter's of those I engage with readily
the most poisonous in a way that's the
most it's not the most violent there are
others that are more violent but it's
it's really a street as I mention in the
beginning where you walk down the street
and people are throwing potted plants at
your head for no apparent reason and
yelling at you and calling you names and
it's it's really a pretty nasty
neighborhood not very friendly Facebook
is significantly better I think in part
because there is less anonymity it's
significantly better in my experience
and then a one level further would be
maybe it's just my experience but
Instagram I find Instagram to be a much
much friendlier environment so I'm most
inclined to look at a say the entire
bulk of comments to a specific post on
Instagram because people aren't dicks as
much they're still idiots on Instagram
don't get me wrong and I also have
absolutely no problem with muting or
blocking people so if someone comes to
my profile to my post and they start
berating me I view that as them coming
into my house kicking off their shoes or
keeping their shoes on putting their
feet up on my dinner table and spitting
on the floor so they're not invited back
I routinely block em you'd just without
any regard for whether those people are
having a bad day and they're just off
they're gone it's it's a one strike
you're out policy and if I feel that I
am already pre agitated meaning I have a
lot going on I'm feeling somewhat
reactive or combative I think very
carefully about going on social media
and I think about it specifically at
night and so let's say that I'm going to
have a really late dinner right it's
like 10 o'clock dinner so I'm probably
gonna go to bed within the next two
hours and I'm tempted to go on Twitter
because sometimes I'll look at my say I
look at my verified app mentions like oh
my god
yeah such-and-such basketball player or
such-and-such director or purse athlete
whoever might be listening to my podcast
how cool but that's I would say 20% of
the time
80% of the time there's gonna be someone
who's like Tim Ferriss is a stupid platy
blah blah blah blah blah blah and then
I'm gonna get my knickers in a twist and
I'm gonna be all wound up and
potentially angry right before going to
bed the worst possible time for me to be
stuck in my head considering
hypothetical arguments and how I could
win those arguments not productive not
helpful so I think about that I'm like
if I turn on this phone and I look at
Twitter there's an 80% chance that I
will have a bad outcome okay let's not
do it and I put it down so those are a
few of the ways that I think about
managing social media so to speak
managing by neglect and so cultivating
selective ignorance I think is very very
important because you have in social
media companies with billions of dollars
of capital in R&D and advertising and
product development whose sole job is to
take you off task and one of the most
effective ways to take you off task is
to make you angry alright this is what
many of the polarizing news outlets have
figured out and you just for a very very
long time if it bleeds it leads if I can
scare you make you upset that takes you
off task so the advertisements you're
gonna see might do that and certainly I
think in today's political climate
people are more interested in fighting
than reconciling it would appear that
majority of people are taking what I
would consider the lesser route to
making themselves feel better
right so you can make yourself better or
you can make yourself feel better
those are not the same thing you make
yourself better by evaluating your own
weaknesses by evaluating your own
strengths and working on yourself it's
hard work it takes focus it takes
dedication you'll have painful moments
but ultimately in the long term it makes
everything easier so as one of my
mentors Jersey Greg would say easy
choice is hard life hard choices easy
life all right so you can make yourself
better you wanna make yourself feel
better you care other people down and
you throw mud and you spend time on
social media biting ankles and that
might feel good in the short term but in
the long term you're going to lose
you're gonna lose in competition and
you're gonna lose your own self-respect
and that I think is the perhaps the
ultimate travesty
so some thoughts on social media but
focus on making yourself better not
making other people feel worse and
yourself feel better
that's a loser's game all right and when
in doubt [ __ ] starve it of oxygen and
focus on what you're supposed to be
doing because social media ain't yes
generally speaking good luck so I get
asked a fair amount how do you contend
with the sheer volume of information and
advice that you hear and receive from
say podcast guests right because I'm
doing six podcast episodes a month they
are two to four hours in length
typically and it could seem that I and
maybe even my listeners would be getting
waterboarded with details to the extent
that they wouldn't be able to absorb or
assimilate them and it's pretty simple
for me there are a few there are a few
different tactics and I would say
beliefs that allow me to get a lot out
of it without feeling overwhelmed the
first is actually something that relates
to writing after doing extensive
of research because you suffer from the
same problem I have 15 notebooks with
1500 pages of notes and I'm writing a
200 page book if you're not me how am I
gonna condense all this how am I going
to remember the most important parts and
what Cal fuss men who is an incredible
writer and also very gifted interviewer
was taught at one point by a very famous
novelist and then he told me this story
was the good [ __ ] sticks all right so
the good [ __ ] sticks just means don't
stress about it
the really standout stuff has a strong
foothold in your mind and it will either
stay with you or it will come to you
when you need it so have that confidence
if you are paying attention and you're
present when you take the notes and
you're present when you are listening to
people so that it can make an initial
imprint the good [ __ ] sticks just have
that faith I hate to use that word
typically but just to have the faith
that if you're if you're present and
really paying attention when you're
reading or writing something down or
listening to someone that the imprint
has been made and the good [ __ ] has
stuck that's number one number two is
actually borrowed from Derek Siver's so
very well known entrepreneur a
philosopher king of sorts in the
programming worlds also a tremendous
musician and his policy for evaluating
opportunities is if it's not a hell yes
it's a no all right so if it's not a
hell yes it's a decline and I think that
similarly when I'm interviewing someone
and I have a notebook at all times I'm
interviewing someone if they say
something that really grabs me I mean
it's not oh that's kind of cool it's
like wow I get pulled by the shirt what
the [ __ ] that so oh my god to me I have
to do that then I note it down all right
if it's lukewarm
I don't highlight it if it's lukewarm
kind of cool I pay attention
it makes the imprint but I don't note it
down so at the end of say any given
three hour interview I may only have
four or five highlights of things I want
to test what's important at that point
is that I put it into a calendar if you
want to try something
or if you want to purchase something
within the two hours after that
interview I set down some type of next
step so either go on say Amazon Prime
boom I bought it I'll have in two days
or I go into my calendar it's like okay
I want to commit to scheduling say voice
lessons after I did podcast with a very
well-known musician all right I want to
schedule voice lessons it's got to be
done now or it's just never gonna happen
so as soon as I finished I got him to
slack stir to communicate with my
assistant I also did some preliminary
research looked at my calendar as to
where I would be thought about what my
parameters and criteria might be and
boom it's in motion right so in my world
and in many worlds if doesn't happen now
or it's not put into the calendar it's
not gonna happen it will never happen
right so that's part two and I would
also say part three is another belief
and that is you don't have to do a
million things right you really just
have to get a few things right and have
first principles which is why I enjoyed
so much my interview with Ray Dalio who
manages the largest hedge fund in the
world he is always thinking about first
principles because you have principles
strategies tactics and then everything
else right for instance if you want to
be an artist okay you could use every
latest tech tool the different crayons
and markers and pencils and get really
stressed out about which of these to use
but ultimately you need to have the fine
motor control and then you need to have
the ability to see right so learning to
be an artist or learning to be a
physicist in some ways is learning how
to see which is what IDI Catmull
president of Pixar it said to me and I
thought very deeply about this okay this
is a first principle I can think about
that and if I cultivate that skill my
ability to observe that then filters
down to 20 other fields okay so if you
don't fixate on the tiny little tool so
they can be fun
the apps and so on don't get me wrong if
it grabs you by the shirt and you're
excited try it but you only have to get
a few things
right and by that I mean you only need
to cultivate a handful of skills
deal-making negotiating nonviolent
communication prioritization by say
reading something like the effective
executive by Peter Drucker and you're
good you're gonna win at the game of
life
if you don't drown in the lower-level
detail right so just have the confidence
that it's not about doing a million
things right
it's actually about saying yes hell yes
to a handful of things and then saying
no thank you
to a thousand ten thousand other things
so those are a few of the approaches
that I use and I often will very
frequently use Evernote to keep track of
different notes that I've taken on
various interviews and with articles
online for instance I will pull them
using the Evernote clipper offline into
Evernote and I will read all these
articles in Evernote and when I find
little tidbits that I find useful unlike
say Kindle or you can highlight things
and then review your highlights in
Evernote with something that's just a
mishmash pulled off the internet what
I'll do is I will put three asterisks
before what I find really interesting
and then bold and underline it then all
I need to do is in those notes if I want
to do a quick refresh and what I found
very important at the time is I'll do a
ctrl F which is fine and it'll say found
seven instances of star star star boom
and then five minutes I can do my review
and I would say last but not least try
to specialize in as I mentioned first
principles and those higher-level tools
but secondarily try to focus in Kathy
Sierra who's amazing first said it this
way to me on just-in-time information
not just in case information so if you
think about it like how many books have
you read non-fiction books you're like
just in case I need this I'm interested
in I remember way back in the
import/export I want to be an
import-export this is a long time ago
and I read it and that was with the
understanding but I
was not with all too much clarity that I
probably wouldn't use that for years so
what happens if I need to use it years
from then that's a book I just need to
reread the damn book so instead of doing
that focus on just-in-time information
so it's like all right I have this to do
tomorrow next week these are the ways I
can prepare them and you're on it
instead of just in case information and
that also relieves a huge psychological
burden oh hi thank you for joining me
for another video
this is my dog Molly and this is a
wooden wine glass I'm gonna talk to you
about mistakes that people make
networking what a dirty word that is and
I'll talk a little bit about how I've
built my own network as it were my
advice in short is to go narrow and to
go along all right so that involves deep
relationships with a small number of
people and then playing the long game
what many people do is they go to an
event to collect business cards and then
they follow up with people with whom
they have no common interests in the
hopes of some type of transaction in the
near term the next few weeks the next
few months that can work but what I
would suggest you do is if we're looking
at events which can be very very high
yield look at either volunteer events
where you can volunteer all right or
super high-end events where you can
attend and pay a premium to attend and
in the former category I can give an
example of a tipping point for the
4-hour workweek my first book and that
came about by going in part to South by
Southwest 2007 and my tactic was as an
attendee here which is fairly expensive
to go to moderated panels and then when
a panel ended instead of flooding the
scene to get in line to talk to a
panelist I would actually talk to the
moderator who people tend to ignore and
I would be very very humble to the
extent I could and say it's my first
time South by Southwest I'm
pretty nervous I just wrote my first
book I don't know anybody not gonna
pretend to understand everything about
tack I don't but I'm really interested
in ABCDE and I'm originally from this
part of the world and these are some of
my interests is there anyone you think I
might enjoy meeting here now you have
say Mary or Joe whoever saying yeah you
should meet Mike such-and-such then I go
and find Mike or I'm introduced to Mike
and I already have that social stamp of
approval of one person okay now I meet
that person and we talk and there's no
explicit ask it was really important I
do the same thing just got the South by
Southwest my first time here
I apologize kind of a random
introduction but I don't know anybody
and I have my first book out I really
don't know what to do because I have my
launch coming up but I'm here to learn
that's it I'm here to learn and meet
people I don't even know what to ask for
and talk to them talk to them talk to
them and then if the timing seems right
and it may not may never be right but if
it is you can ask you know is there
anybody else here you think I should
meet up with or buy a drink for who can
I buy a round of drinks for just to have
fun
cool people who I might be able to hang
out with and who might enjoy hanging out
with me and then you go to the second
person and so on and now all the way up
to this point I've not made a single ask
alright other than the question is there
anybody else you think I might enjoy
meeting now at some point you will then
have a small gaggle of people and
probably you'll be buying booze leaves
that's my tactic it's fairly fairly easy
to buy booze for people and then
everyone's talking so let's say you have
a group of people in tech or you have a
dog what street is coming back to say
hello a bunch of people in tech we're
talking about tech things and they're
saying things like blabbity blabbity
blah Ruby on Rails I don't know what
that is as a guy I'm talking to the guys
here because women generally don't have
this problem don't pretend like you know
everything it's really not endearing so
they would say something like blah blah
blah Ruby on Rails and I would say
you know so sorry to interrupt this is
deep in the end of my ignorance pool I
don't know what Ruby on Rails is what is
Ruby on Rails and every once in a while
I would interject and ask for
clarification just to learn eventually
after two or three rounds of drinks
someone will say who are you again like
what do you do what are you doing here
and then you can offer a little bit you
say something like well I just finished
my first book I'm really nervous it's
coming out on such and such a date and I
don't know what a book launch is so I'm
here to try to meet people and learn
different skills to figure that out and
then you stop you don't give them a
two-minute or three-minute pitch and
chances are someone will ask okay well
what's your book about and then you can
give a little bit more and then let's
say you're in a group of eight people
you watch the one or two who are going
to have more follow-up questions and
then eventually maybe in a group of
eight people you say to one of them
afterwards you say look I have a ton of
books that my publisher has sent me
these are review copies and advance
copies I don't know what to do with them
I don't think you'd actually read the
whole book but there's there's a 20-page
bit then I think you'd really enjoy on X
Y & Z because you know that you've
already ascertained it through the
conversation you had and you say you
know if it wouldn't be a burden if you'd
enjoy it maybe I could send it to you
but if not that's cool
and I would say 90% of the time they
said yeah sure that'd be cool I'd love
to see it and that's how it all happened
guys that's how the book hit then your
toughest self worth list it was by doing
that over and over again and this is the
key point you don't have to be a
networking [ __ ] you don't have to sell
yourself to the highest bidder or
compromise and spend time with people
you don't like you can find people who
are a-class players in a given world who
you want to spend time with who have
similar values and hobbies so that one
person out of the ten who said yeah cool
no I'd love to check it out the vast
majority of those people from eleven
years ago are still my friends today
and that's going narrow and going long
oh right should you write a book should
someone or anyone write a book I get
asked questions about launching books
all the time how can I make my book a
best-seller
have you written the book no I'm going
to write a book have you written any
books before no why are you writing a
book and we get into this conversation
and ultimately I ask one question and
that is for the period of a year can you
make this your number one priority for a
period of at least a year can this be
your number one if you have a company
that means your business is number two
if you have a family that means your
family is number two can this be your
number one priority for a year that's
the general litmus test because if you
put out a mediocre book or even a good
book a good enough book which by the way
equals shitty as Brian Grazer legendary
film and TV producer would say it's more
of a liability than a help okay so a
mediocre book is more of a liability
than no book at all you can't take it
back so as Michael Gerber told me who
wrote the e-myth revisited which is a
book that had a huge impact on me before
I launched the 4-hour workweek he said
if you're going to write a book write a
[ __ ] book meaning like you're all in
all of your chips are into this book so
how did I know that I should do four
hour workweek right was it that obvious
was it cleared it was I dying to be a
writer which by the way I don't think is
a necessary checkbox you don't have to
write the book yourself necessarily open
by Andre Agassi by the way August
Andre Agassi was ghostwritten but it was
a collaboration that took a long time
and a lot of Andres time beautifully
written but nonetheless required a lot
of focus from him so you can have a
collaborator but my I suppose hurdle was
it was easier for me to get out of my
head than it was for me to live with it
in my head all right
it was less painful to put it down than
to have it ricocheting inside my head
and I had all these experiences from
2004 to say end of 2005 where I was
restructuring and reformulating my
entire business to run without me
traveling the world for 18 months
without any set schedule meeting all
these case studies and I was teaching a
class at Princeton twice a year
sometimes in person sometimes remotely
in high tech entrepreneurship whereas
sharing my findings about scaling a
bootstrapped business and that slowly
morphed into lifestyle design how to
create a business or career to allow you
to take advantage of the most valuable
non-renewable resource which is time so
I'm already giving these two to
three-hour classes and I would take
notes and over time because one of the
students said why don't you just write a
book and be done with it as opposed to
teaching a class of 40 students which
was actually a snarky Princeton student
response it wasn't a real suggestion I
don't think nonetheless I had insomnia
for many many many many years and I
couldn't get to sleep because these
chapter ideas would come these stories
would come to mind and I just couldn't
get to sleep without jotting down a
little note on a piece of paper and I
ended up with a huge pile of paper on
lessons learned and so on and I knew
that at least two of my friends and
there were two specific friends in mind
one who is trapped in a decent paying
job where he had no time disliked what
he was doing but he could he could
finally afford that nice car right so he
felt like he was trapped and then I had
a friend who had started his own company
who similarly is making decent money but
felt trapped in a monster of his own
making and I felt these notes would help
them okay did not want to write a book
at that point actively did not want to
write a book alright but I felt a moral
obligation to share this material
somehow and a few of my friends who were
authors recommended that I explore the
path to publishing it and I made a few
assumptions going into it because keep
in mind I did not want to write a book I
assumed it was gonna be extremely
difficult and brutal to write the book
which it was and we're talking
moments of doubt I should throw in the
towel I am going to have a nervous
breakdown
repeatedly okay that is more or less
been the case for every book that I've
written I'm at five now okay the second
assumption was that I was going to
probably hate the book itself which I
did okay and that has been largely true
for every book I've done assume that up
until a year after the book comes out
you're gonna look at it and be
disappointed with what you've produced
given that the third assumption was that
I would write the book and if it even
changed the life of one or two people
that would justify all the pain all the
self-loathing all the loathing of the
book all of the opportunity cost of
putting it together right and that last
but not least it was easier for me less
painful for me to get it out and throw a
Hail Mary and hope for the best then to
keep it inside of me and wonder what if
okay so a lot of different checkboxes
and the book keep in mind for our work
week was rejected by 27 publishers and
then when it was finally printed first
print run was about 10,000 copies you
don't even get national distribution
with that nobody really expected a whole
lot and then with the same amount of
focus that I put into the writing put
into launch ended up hitting the New
York Times bestseller list and now it's
millions of copies in 40-plus languages
okay but I don't think you get to
millions of copies and 40-plus languages
trying to write a book for the world
that is going to help your business I
just don't think it happens I've never
seen it happen and instead check all the
boxes that I mentioned and I wrote this
book for two friends very specifically
and by personalizing it in that way by
talking to them in a in a very
conversational way we ended up with the
results that we had could have very
easily gone a different direction but if
you can listen to everything I've just
said and you think to yourself I should
write a book then by all means go for it
but for most people this doesn't mean I
am a great writer therefore
you need to be a great writer no I'm
just saying it was less painful for me
to put it out than to keep it in my head
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter you may have heard them
everywhere they're growing up crazy
they're an innovative platform for doing
several things but especially improving
the hiring process making it slick and
elegant and easy one of the hardest
parts of running any business growing
any business is finding and hiring the
right team I've seen this firsthand in
close to a hundred startups now got a
big ole
from all over the world of different
stages of growth and nothing can quite
drain your resources and cost you time
and money
like making mistakes in hiring Zipp
recruiter developed their own system and
their own platform for helping you to
solve two of the biggest problems and
bottlenecks for employers posting jobs
easily and then making it even easier to
find the best candidates
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
does in effect the opposite of what
you'd expect so they do not depend on
candidates finding you their technology
finds the right candidate for you and in
fact more than 80% of the jobs posted on
zip recruiter return a qualified
candidate based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours
so no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of them simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
on zip recruiters dashboard and as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show thanks
for that zip recruiter wants to allow
you to start posting jobs and trying
their services for free so if you think
of hire somebody you need to find
anything an executive assistant you need
to find developer whatever it might be
try it out just visit zip recruiter com4
slash Tim and you can experience just
how super critter has been used by
businesses of all different sizes to
find that you must qualify job
candidates again that's recruiter comm
or slash Tim
give it a spin this episode is brought
to you by athletic greens every year
of course people look for new ways to
become healthier to take their fitness
and so on to the next level for me step
number one is having some form of
nutritional insurance that's how I would
look at it and the nutritional insurance
needs to make sure all of my basic needs
are met all the boxes checked regardless
of travel schedule missed meals and so
on there are going to be times in the
new year when your diet and exercise
will get interrupted life will interrupt
it then during those times you want a
safety net I get asked all the time if
you could only use one supplement what
would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens calm poet / Tim that is a great
deal on one of my favorite products and
it covers my basis in today it is part
of my routine and it leaves me with less
to worry about if for instance I have to
skip a meal or for just can't get
high-quality meal so check it out go to
athletic greens comm forward slash Tim
and learn all about
you